[♪♪♪]
JUDGE JEANINE: HELLO AND WELCOME
TO "JUSTICE," I'M JUDGE JEANINE
PIRRO.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO MY OPEN.
IN CASE YOU DIDN'T KNOW IT, JOE
BIDEN IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IN NAME ONLY.
SOMEONE ELSE IS RUNNING THE
WHITE HOUSE.
BARACK OBAMA MAYBE?
COME ALONG WITH ME AND SEE WHAT
IT MAKES SENSE.
FROM THE BEGINNING OF HIS
CAMPAIGN WE KNEW HE WASN'T
RIGHT.
WE KEPT ASKING OURSELVES WHAT
WAS WRONG WITH HIM.
>> NO MAN HAS A RIGHT TO RAISE A
HAND TO A WOMAN IN ANGER OTHER
THAN SELF-DEFENSE AND THAT
RARELY EVER OCCURS.
SO WE HAVE TO CHANGE THE CULTURE
AND KEEP PUNCHING AT IT AND
PUNCHING AT IT.
>> I HAD HAIRY LEGS THAT TURN
BLOND IN THE SUN.
AND THE KIDS USED TO COME IN AND
REACH IN THE POOL AND RUB MY
LEGS DOWN.
CORN POP WAS A BAD DUDE AND HE
RAN A BUNCH OF BAD BOYS.
>> MAKE SURE YOU HAVE THE RECORD
PLAYER ON AT NIGHT.
JUDGE JEANINE: WE COULDN'T ASK
QUESTIONS BECAUSE THEY KEPT
PULLING HIM BACK BEHIND THE
CURTAIN LIKE THEY WERE HIDING
SOMETHING.
BUT EVEN THEN HE WAS OFTEN WHERE
HE WAS OR WHERE HE WAS GOING.
>> HOW YOU [INAUDIBLE] HOW YOUR
MEETINGS GOING IN CORNWALL?
>> VERY WELL.
JUDGE JEANINE: WITH THE HELP OF
BIG TECH AND MARK ZUCKERBERG, NO
NEGATIVE STORIES ABOUT JOE BIDEN
AND THAT HUNTER BIDEN LAPTOP
WERE ALLOWED TO SEE THE LIGHT OF
DAY.
AND JOE BIDEN BECAME THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
TO CONTINUE THE CHARADE THE
WHITE HOUSE BUILT A FAKE OFFICE
FOR JOE BIDEN IN THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICE BUILDING.
BIDEN DOESN'T TAKE QUESTIONS
FROM JOURNALISTS.
THE REAL REASON, HE CAN READ A
SCRIPT FROM A MONITOR WITHOUT
THE TELEPROMPTER GLASS THAT CAN
BE SEEN ON CAMERA, I.E., WITHOUT
YOUR KNOWING.
AS LONG AS HE CAN READ, HE
DOESN'T HAVE TO THINK.
AS ONLOOKERS, WE STRUGGLE.
IS HE A LIAR OR SIMPLY
INCOMPETENT, UNAWARE?
HE SAYS ONE THING AND DOES
ANOTHER.
>> SHOULD VACCINES BE MANDATORY.
>> NO.
I DON'T THINK THEY SHOULD BE
MANDATORY JUST LIKE I DON'T
THINK MASKS SHOULD BE MANDATORY
NATIONWIDE.
JUDGE JEANINE: THEN HE REVERSES
HIMSELF AND SAYS HE NEVER WAS
TOLD ESSENTIAL TRUTHS BY HIS
MILITARY.
EACH OF WHOM CONGRESS EXTRA
DICTD HIM.
>> IT'S BEEN A STABLE SITUATION
FOR THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS.
WE CAN CONTINUE TO DO THAT.
>> NO ONE SAID THAT TO ME ATTIC
RECALL.
JUDGE JEANINE: THE REPEATED
STATEMENTS THAT HE'S GOING TO
GET INTO TROUBLE IF HE KEEPS
ANSWERING QUESTIONS.
>> I'M GOING TO GET IN TROUBLE
WITH STAFF IF I DON'T DO THIS
THE RIGHT WAY.
>> I'M GOING TO GET IN TROUBLE.
JUDGE JEANINE: NO PRESIDENT IN
UNITED STATES HISTORY HAS EVER
SPOKEN LIKE THIS.
WHAT ARE WE SUPPOSED TO CONCLUDE
WHEN THE MOST POWERFUL MAN IN
THE FREE WORLD SAYS SOMEONE WILL
REPRIMAND HIM IF HE DOESN'T DO
WHAT THEY TELL HIM TO DO.
IS SOMEONE ELSE IN CHARGE?
HAVE YOUING IN THED JOE BIDEN IS
CARE -- HAVE YOU NOTICED THAT
JOE BIDEN IS CARRYING OUT THE
SAME POLICIES BARACK OBAMA HAD.
LOOK AT THIS GRAPH OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO WORKED IN THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION WHO ARE NOW
WORKING FOR JOE BIDEN.
AND BY THE WAY, HOW IS IT THAT
KAMALA HARRIS WHO IS JOE BIDEN'S
CHOICE FOR VICE PRESIDENT WAS
EVEN GIVEN THAT OPPORTUNITY
GIVEN THE FACT THAT SHE CALLED
HIM OUT ON HIS RACIST BELIEFS.
AND WHY WOULD SOMEONE AS
CLUELESS AS CACKLER KAMALA WHO
HAD TO DROP OUT OF A
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY BECAUSE SHE
COULDN'T GET 1%.
HOW IS IT SHE IS NOW THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
THINK BACK TO BARACK OBAMA'S
AFFECTION FOR KAMALA HARRIS.
YOU HAVE TO BE CAREFUL TO SAY
SHE IS BRILLIANT AND DEDICATED
AND SHE IS TOUGH AND EXACTLY
WHAT YOU WANT.
AND ANYBODY ADMINISTERING THE
LAW AND MAKING SURE EVERYONE IS
GETTING A FAIR SHAKE.
ACCORDING TO BARACK OBAMA SHE
HAPPENS TO BE BY FAR THE BEST
LOOKING ATTORNEY GENERAL IN THE
COUNTRY.
AND YOU REMEMBER DURING THE
DEBATE PHASE OF THE PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN, IT WAS REPORTED THAT
JOE BIDEN'S HANDLERS AGREED TO A
PREDEBATE INSPECTION FOR
ELECTRONIC EARPIECES.
SHORTLY BEFORE THE DEBATE THEY
REVERSED THEMSELVES AND
DECLINED.
AS TO THE ELECTION, WHEN
DISCUSSING WITH STEPHEN COLBERT
ON WHAT A THIRD TERM COULD HAVE
LOOKED LIKE, BARACK OBAMA SAID
THE FOLLOWING.
>> I USED TO SAY, IF I COULD
MAKE AN ARRANGEMENT WHERE I HAD
A STAND-IN, A FRONT MAN OR WOMAN
AND THEY HAD AN EARPIECE IN AND
I WAS IN MY BASEMENT IN MY
SWEATS, I COULD CERTAIN OF
DELIVER THE LINES BUT SOMEBODY
ELSE IS DOING ALL THE TALKING.
I WOULD BE FINE WITH THAT.
JUDGE JEANINE: SO I ASK YOU, WHO
DO YOU THINK IS RUNNI